et adieu regarde ça c'est le soutien
aérien
ils sont tous morts un seul homme peut
redonner une telle attaque et j'ai voté
pour lui
chers amis chefs d'état vous contemplez
nouvelles armes de pointe capable
d'anéantir 14 fois chacun de vos pays
qu'un soit dans le cas de la corée du
nord juste en appuyant sur un bouton
et si le président n'était pas le
président
vous êtes fous pour notre gouvernement
pour nos familles toute trace de notre
existence a été balayée a priori on peut
faire confiance à personne
il reste un homme peut-être
ça va ouais et vous ça va j'ai un peu de
cholestérol
il reste plus que nous alors au boulot
qu'ont fait pas
il porte au nez
bienvenue en enfer
[Musique]
général